So now that we've played Avatar's movie trailer, here's your
challenge. I want you to comment out this line, the
line that shows the trailer for Avatar. Then, I want
you to create a new object, but this time of your
favorite movie, and I want you to play its trailer
instead. Here are the instructions one more time. Much like Toy
Story and Avatar, we want you to create a new
instance or object of the class Movie. Once you've done that,
we want you to play a trailer of that
movie using the new instance or object. And finally,
we want you to share a screenshot of your
program's output on the discussion forum. Now, in case you
have a way to video record your computer screen,
perhaps using a smartphone, you can also share a Youtube
video of your output with us. Make sure to
check this box after submitting your response on the forum.